what's going on guys Greg Alva here
about to watch another episode of the
defenders episode six right now once I'm
done watching all the episodes I will do
a full series review with my buddy
Andrew from the movie source channel
only show about five or ten minutes
worth of a reaction using footage on the
show but I so just include whatever
moments stand out to me I guess yeah I
just want to watch this watch it well
come on stick don't do this no I called
it two episodes ago he's good
[Music]
or mash the governance top
stick
bad decision-making new hours ever said
I didn't know what you were she was
right
you were our weapon but they made you
there you serve come along as well as
you could with any luck stick them do it
man
[Music]
do you got killer
he'll arrive
[Music]
yes
you know more this is not anymore
she's gonna do it
Oh
[Music]
damn strong but she totally
and it didn't want steak to die
[Music]
all is lost people
oh and there's a lecture yup ya fool
you just got proven wrong oh defeat look
at that face if you knew me at all
you know I always win
[Music]
Sigourney Weaver was perfectly cast
Electra's weapons mr. Rand I know I
speak for all of us when I say how nice
it is to have you with us again this
time for good this war it isn't over
well the thing about war is it only
works at both sides believe they're the
good guys you fight to defeat us if I
could impact what was once House
Beautiful to return to come on it's
possible
I saw the head you saw what you wanted
to see the truth is you and I we're not
so different
we're not so different you and I we both
want nothing more than to return to it
now without death standing in our way I
believe we can together no we have not
the same yeah
but in the end
and this is the end you'll do what
everyone else does for me
you'll serve
well now that he's taken care of we can
proceed as planned
dude you're always bitching bitching
this moment forth our sole focus is to
secure the substance before him do not
underestimate me kill Luke Cage kill
Jessica Jones and the devil of Hell's
Kitchen whoever he is I'm so happy
you're all on board with the plan but
let me remind you what exactly i
neutralize our enemies I brought you the
iron fist I was able to keep the most
important operation in our history
running while you succumb to chaos and
conflict I have proven myself to be the
one and only true
oh you got cottonmouth sorta his
electron that shows Oh
[Music]
so many deaths in this episode
oh whoa
I didn't think something like that would
happen to like the very last episode she
got killed off early and in a surprise
whoa is totally changes the direction of
the show that I thought it was going
down big-time oh my god
stick dying that's a that's a real
bummer I really didn't want stick to die
dude I felt like the show was setting up
for him to die in this season just kind
of didn't wanted to happen electric
killing Alexandra it's kind of a
cottonmouth Scituate it's a sort of
caught in math oh just a bit in terms of
like you know a few episodes before the
season wraps up that they have the main
daddy get killed off she's just got so
much more defense yeah cuz now it seems
like a lecture is aware of her past and
who she was before she was resurrected
but as what iron fist the show showed
with Harold Meacham like I could just
imagine with already who a lecturer was
before she died and now that she's been
resurrected for her to kill the person
who brought her back and essentially
become the new head of the hand oh she
must be she must be some real dark fat
wonder what's gonna happen with her
Karen I really do wonder what's gonna
happen and this totally changes
everything between Matt and Aleya oh my
god Matt has had his issues with stick
but you would have never wanted him to
be killed especially by the woman he
loves this is a really strong episode
for me me I I don't I could honestly see
I have no idea how people have responded
to these two deaths in terms of like
when they were watching the show how
they felt about it I've talked about it
with anyone yet but to kill off the
stick and then Alexander like both in
the same effort that's some bold [ __ ] it
was like borderline Game of Thrones
territory right there the first scene in
this episode I thought was really cool
watching Matt versing Danny was really
cool Ito Geritol versus iron fist which
makes the whole scene where stick is
telling Matt that matt has to become
leader of the group even more effective
and honestly you Finn Jones you know
just I keep mentioning this still not a
super powerful actor still there's a lot
of like head shaking and like a little
annoying nuances here and there but hey
you know what people still talk a lot
[ __ ] on him I'm enjoying him way more in
this show
and I did in his solo show and I really
do enjoy seeing the dynamics of Matt and
Jessica developing it's like instead of
just butting heads there's a moment
where she's in his apartment and he
cracks a joke and it makes him genuinely
laugh you know like when Charlie Cox
with Matt Murdock smiles he just looks
genuinely happy I love his smile I like
when she uses Matt's story to talk to
the daughter and I use it to relate and
connect with her I thought that was a
very effective moment it shows that
Jessica understands who Matt is I just
really like seeing the two of them get
him along it's like I like their banter
I like their back-and-forth but you know
when they get along it warms my heart I
mentioned this a few times I don't mind
talking about it again because it's
something that I think for fans of like
Power Man and Iron Fist they wanted to
see scenes like this as might not be to
the full extent that they were hoping
for but I think the scenes with Luke and
Danny are fantastic when Danny is tied
up and Luke decides to you know talk
with Danny about Danny fighting the
dragon that moment brought a genuine
smile to my face
I like seeing Luke's understanding of
that Danny is just a kid with a lot of
potential and that Danny has a lot to
learn about getting his [ __ ] under
control Luke's a lot wiser and like I
think Luke has the approach of if Luke
is understanding that could allow Danny
to be more understanding but as in first
I guess on my reaction man dude stick
stick die that was a bummer I'm gonna
miss him maybe it'll bring him back like
I said a couple episodes ago I thought
stick would die kind of not a big fan of
the way he went out in this episode it
makes sense like in terms of direction
of how everything was going and like 6
choice to actually try to kill Danny and
that make sense - I just I don't know a
little bit more of a rewarding death for
stick and then just overall intensifies
everything with electric okay oh well
I'm gonna take a little break and watch
the next two episodes another day man
you got a lot to absorb
alright if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow me at the Greg album on Instagram
and Twitter and go to our patreon and
become a page fraud object today if you
haven't already become one